el distrito de iu está en los
alrededores de jartúm es una de las
partes más pobres de la capital sudanesa
es también el hogar de una importante
comunidad cristiana
igual que muchos otros en sudán están
preocupados por los disturbios en el
país
es terrible para nosotros como sudaneses
ver que nuestra sangre se vierta tan
fácilmente porque la gente muere por
estar pidiendo paz y una vida mejor es
una vergüenza que estemos temerosos de
perder lo ganado en los últimos tiempos
el sentimiento de paz y libertad que
habíamos comenzado a sentir hoy tenemos
nueve de no encontrar la paz y del
sombrío en certero futuro que afronta
sudando
cerca del lugar otra iglesia comparte la
misma ansiedad
[Aplausos]
bajo el régimen de omar al bashir los
cristianos fueron discriminados y sus
iglesias fueron destruidas cani scarlett
fokina busquets el etf o con la iglesia
queda un poco más abajo fue destruida
pensábamos aquí bajo el sol durante
meses las autoridades el antiguo régimen
lo destruyó no pudimos luchar por ellos
la gente en el poder hace lo que quiere
tenemos miedo de que los militares
restauran el viejo régimen
durante la revolución de 2019 mejoró
sustancialmente la vida de los
cristianos aunque no alcanzaron la
igualdad
esta mujer continúa dando la batalla
para preservar las pocas conquistas que
se ganaron serca con lo que me movilizó
como todos los sudaneses queremos un
estado civil y democrático en donde todo
el mundo tenga sus derechos sin importar
su religión que todo el mundo tenga
acceso a los servicios básicos
los cristianos de ciudadan esperan poder
continuar practicando su fe en libertad
como cualquier creyente de otra fe
esperan poder dar un futuro mejor a sus
hijos